hello and welcome to zo playing broker
with wide yet I did not upload the last
game it was really it was a draw i hate
moves and it was a line where i played
against someone with exactly my reading
and there was a funny line where I'm
where my opponent can force a draw by
repetition and surprisingly he did he
did force the draw so really not much I
could do about it it was just like and
pretty much unavoidable draw them so i
didn't i didn't upload that 7108 more
game i'm not quite sure what it was okay
broker he's going for a 5b 5c 5 and so
on and looks fairly aggressive I want to
play the scent as I usually do not much
into violating all principals at once so
d for now looks like the way to to do it
it's very sharp though okay that's seen
before i go d 5 is taking this okay one
of those guys who really doesn't care
what the other guy does okay whatever
let's see what let's see what happens
how we handle this handles this he moves
the bishop d6 should win a piece and if
it takes a feathered pin will be
difficult okay d6 Bishop takes Bishop f4
how do you avoid material losses now can
also take with an might but then bishop
six is a bit bit of an issue so Bishop
here and what's coming here ropy 800 k 6
I can take here with the night right now
Bishop a 6 is not coming okay eight is
there there's some square I should go to
then I was thinking wouldn't be too
actually
able to do some stuff now I don't see
how he avoids it wow this one
ok
ok let's start the dismals and now if I
just very attack yet
I'm not quite sure him he still has this
this a na this is Pawn situation here
222 is the easiest looking move the
night has no squares does he have some
tricky rhythm I don't see it but it kind
of feels like there could be some trick
don't don't see anything here for him
but it feels still like something
strange could happen just don't see it
rookie a to go just take 26 okay so
spaceship with five some may be Bishop
b5 first or something or if i take a
rook da does this idea I can't go we
should be five roped it to bishop checks
of six that really doesn't really
doesn't do the trick and I have to play
now I have to play more
misc what I did I blunder this [ __ ]
yeah I did oh my thought I cannot leave
that okay now night takes maybe maybe
maybe I can still keep something here I
could be should be seven or something
like that things i might have beat or
some nonsense okay come on this is
complete completely time morning
terrible position it was that must have
been a complete win and he somehow
swindled himself all of it I probably
swimmable to swindle him out of it
it's not much that I can do in this
still looks kind of nice but there is no
real way for any any progress IAM
DRA offered that should just win now and
I didn't didn't find it funny enough the
computer doesn't give a win here but it
should give a win after that I cannot
believe that I can survive that so Nyjah
five wins and that doesn't Queen f6 is
whole lenses Queen B 2 wins Queen B to
win soon yeah this was killing
absolutely killing can I mean yeah
that's 94 now in addition it's not so
easy for you me play you have so many
possibilities I get confused in such a
position yeah yeah I'm its own your cool
moves but it's some howls yeah this this
this check check yeah and now I cannot
win I mean I can do this and then yes
the phone I mean it's a miracle defense
but it works yeah we should be seven was
maybe a little bit tougher here yeah
it's it looks like some advantage but I
was bit unnerved by the by now King III
is still having some chances
such a spoiled opportunity Queen B 5 was
also quite strong this the simple move
just for being a poner but d6 look so
nice ok thanks for watching